Russia's gas pipelines have just been
blown up leading us closer to World War
III as you're watching this these
pipelines are spilling an insane amount
of natural gas into the ocean the
question is who did this if you listen
to mainstream media they say it's flat
who else would it be but Vlad blowing up
his own pipeline just doesn't make any
sense these pipelines are the source of
vlad's power of vlad's wealth it's the
last piece of Leverage he has over
Europe to get them to stop supporting
Ukraine but you know who would benefit
from the Russian pipelines blowing up
the US think about it no pipeline means
Putin has less power in fact here's what
Biden had to say about the pipelines
back in February if Russian Ray the
border of Ukraine there will be no
longer a Norse team too we we will bring
it into it and right after the
explosions the former polish foreign
minister tweeted out this thank you USA
and then the day after it was sabotaged
what do you know a new pipeline was
unveiled that carries non-russian gas to
Europe which is convenient because now
it has less competition subscribe to
find out what happens next